I woke up this morning to see this video
on my Twitter feed hey Conan can you
believe it's the fifth anniversary of
Let's Move now I've been watching you on
TV for a long time and I haven't noticed
much muscle on those arms so as part of
our Gimme five fifth anniversary
challenge I want you to give me five
chin-ups and when you're done pass the
challenge along to someone else using
the hashtag gimme five
[Applause]
[Music]
what is she talking about not much
muscle I got guns for Andy you've seen
me without my shirt on yeah I thought it
was listening a bird display at the
Museum well guess what first lady I took
your challenge earlier today
take a look alright first lady here are
your five chin-ups let's do it one two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
our thanks to Kevin Hart for helping me
how's that he's in the hospital now I
broke his back all right now I'd like to
pass along the Gimme five challenge I
demand five jumping jacks from the most
fit man I know that perfect human
specimen you all call Bill Nye the
Science Guy
[Applause]
like Bill Nye
you